now 14 year old Molly Russell took her
own life after being bombarded with
suicide and self-harm content online her
family and are trying to educate young
people on the dangers of social media
and they're not the only ones fighting
the cause the center for countering
digital hate recently created a short
movie with actress Laura Linney
within 15 seconds of logging onto social
media the algorithm has your daughter in
its crosshairs it sends her a steady
flow of images telling her she isn't
thin enough pretty enough they invade
her brain
Imran Ahmed from the center for
countering digital hate and Molly's
father Ian are here with us this morning
hi both hello thank you very much indeed
for joining us
um how will the film help
well look it's really important that we
tell parents that these harms are out
there when it comes to a platform like
Tick Tock the truth is that most parents
don't actually know what their kids are
seeing on that platform they can be
sitting next to them on the sofa and
have no idea what influences are being
their kids are being exposed to on
average kids who use tick tock spend 90
minutes a day on it and that's 90
minutes a day when an algorithm is
telling your kid various things without
any parental oversight whatsoever so
it's first of all to remind them that
there is this danger out there the
second thing is to ask for them to take
action because right now our legislators
around the world you know groups like
ccdh have got the backs of parents we're
trying to expose these harms but the
platforms don't have their backs and
legislators don't either and that's in
the UK and the US and the EU right now
we need that comprehensive legislation
and the correct regulations in place so
that platforms can't just get away with
showering our kids with deadly
self-harmony eating disorder content
she didn't see tiktok because yeah it
was Instagram in Molly's case it's
almost the same thing one platform is
very similar to the others their
algorithms are slightly different but
they achieve a similar effect Molly seem
to be a very ordinary normal world but
well behaved well well adjusted uh
school girl we had no concerns about her
there were no obvious signs of any uh
mental ill health
um
and yet one day we got up in the morning
and she was no longer with us
she uh had ended her own life completely
without warning uh one night
and what we discovered on her social
media feeds she did not seem to be a
particular social media person but what
we discovered on her feeds in the weeks
after her death was content
that was
um shocking there was content that
concerns self-harm quite graphically and
there was content more disturbingly that
that suggested
Depression was something you couldn't
get better from which of course is
untrue you can recover from depression
and suggested one of the solutions was
to end your own life and for Global
platforms to be showing content that
suggested that a 14 year old should end
their own life I couldn't believe that
we'd found that this was happening and
happening in a very easy to discover
manner
and in a way what's even more shocking
than that is five years since Molly's
death that same sort of content is still
easy to find on platforms such as
Instagram and tick tock more than that
it's pushed towards young users
so we did some research earlier this
year we set up accounts as 14 year old
girls
um in four different countries so 13
year old girls in four different
countries the UK US Australia and Canada
and we then recorded in the first half
hour of using that as a new account as a
13 year old girl what content did the
algorithmically generate is the
automatically generated for you page
serve up to kids
within 2.6 minutes self-harm content was
being sent to those accounts within
eight minutes eating disorder content
every 39 seconds on average something
potentially harmful was being sent to
kids
and what we found as well was that when
you indicated in any way that you were
vulnerable so half the accounts had a
name like Susan half the accounts had a
name like Susan lose weight and that's
typical of young kids if they are
vulnerable they will they will signify
that through their username or their bio
those accounts that we classified as
vulnerable got 12 times as much
self-harm content in the first 30
minutes the platform responded to those
to that vulnerability not as you and I
would do which is to say this is someone
that we need to be a little bit careful
with it said I know how to addict this
kid they've sent me a sign of their
vulnerability and actually what we can
do what we should do is give them more
of that stuff and it is just so cynical
so irresponsibly designed with no safety
considerations taken into account as
they've built their algorithms which are
designed to to make profit
my concern with that is that right now
there are no consequences for that
behavior there's no transparency of how
these systems works it takes
organizations like mine who do this kind
of work to expose that these things are
happening and the legislation that the
UK is passing right now the Online
safety bill has a real black hole Yeah
will the Online safety Bill help
it has to help the sake of our children
it remains to be seen how effective it's
going to be uh it's in the House of
Lords being debated at the moment
um
I'm not an expert at parliamentary
procedure but along with many families
because it's not just a limited number
of stories sadly there are far too many
families the official figures show that
something like 200 school-aged children
in their lives by suicide every year in
the UK many of those have a connection
with online harms that they've found all
of those families that I've had contact
with are getting quite concerned that as
Amendment after amendment is debated in
the House of Lords nothing seems to be
happening now this might just be normal
parliamentary process I don't know but
it's certainly really frustrated for
those of us who've lost a dearly loved
member of our family and what we need to
see is some changes we need to see first
of all we need to see greater access to
data for bereaved parents so when
tragedies happen
there's a transparency from the platform
so that lessons can be learned to
protect others in the future that seems
to me an obvious and vital lesson so
that's a really important thing for
example and that's one of the Amendments
that's going through Parliament that we
we're really Keen to see movement on as
yet nothing seems to have happened but
maybe that's normal
okay we must leave it there gentlemen
thank you very much for taking the time
to join us this morning thank you
um Tick Tock issue this comment earlier
this month the company has a team of
more than 40 000 people moderating
content they said Tick Tock aims to
remove videos that promote or glorify
self-harm while allowing educational or
recovery content the company said it
continually adjusts its algorithm to
avoid repeatedly recommending a narrow
range of content to viewers